Larry Kudlow is director of the National
Economic Council he's with us from
Washington Larry Kudlow good morning
good morning Thank You Larry I'd like to
start with that farmer from Illinois he
voted for President Trump and he says
this is a bailout
it's a pacifier and it's a bailout he'd
rather not have what would you tell that
farmer well listen I'll tell him how
much I like him he's a patriot and the
Watts word has been trade not aid and I
think that's the case in the majority of
the places some places need some help
you know those have been the reports
from the USDA and so forth sonny perdue
so what we put on the board is what I
think is the temporary assistance
measure I don't think it's going to get
near 12 billion dollars I think that
sums are gonna be much lower so nobody's
really thrilled about this we're just
trying to protect American agriculture
from some of the unfair trading
practices here's the of course the
criticism which you've heard but for
those who haven't and it's coming from
conservatives from The Wall Street
Journal editorial page to a whole
busload of Republicans and the argument
is that this is a fix to do fix
something that the administration
created Wall Street Journal says the
Trump administration is trying to fix an
economic problem of its own making well
I'm afraid you know my good friends at
The Wall Street Journal editorial page
brothers actually and sisters but look
you know I would argue don't blame
President Trump I've said this so often
the world trading system is broken the
WTO is broken
there's no reciprocity left China is the
worst offender but not the only one
around the world this Trump's trying to
fix trading malpractice that goes back
several decades he's the first president
to really stay with this okay tariffs
have gone up non-tariff barriers have
gone up subsidies have gone up there's
no reciprocity as I said it's really
quite unfair it's Trumpets the president
who's initiating these very roughs and
putting these movies i followed you for
all
I think this is saying that they never
intend to work and that they always turn
out badly what's changed may may I just
finished my point yes sir please uh what
I tried to say is that past presidents
in both political parties have tried to
fix the broken world trading system
China is the worst all I'm saying is
this is not of mr. Trump's own making
this is something that mr. Trump
inherited very unfair trading practices
look look at his tweet last evening
something that we developed at the g7
and he said since then he wants a new
system to reform for free trade but that
means no tariffs okay no non-tariff
barriers no subsidies level playing
field reciprocity this is a very
difficult task reform always is there's
a swamp for the world Trading citizen
and he's trying to drain it so I just
with respect I understand the criticism
from friends of mine I do not think this
is of his own making I think he's trying
to fix the cyst and then if he does
you're gonna have even greater
prosperity Larry let me ask you a
question that conservatives have this
issue they say there are always going to
be problems always systems that need to
be fixed always problems that presidents
will inherit and that conservatives when
they come into office they don't
intervene in the market that's the whole
reason they're conservatives and so that
when you intervene in the market using
emergency measures that were not created
to fix these kinds of problems and then
you have to fix the results of those
emergency measures with more emergency
measures that were not intended to fix
these problems that you've gotten way
off the theme of the ideology that is
supposed to be at the core of your
belief system well look I'm I'm a
conservative I regard myself as a
free-market conservative I regard myself
as a free trade conservative as I said
before mr. Trump regards himself as a
free trader well what are you gonna do
you gotta break up you've got to fix a
broken system which is very unfair which
is penalizing so much of the US exports
around the world we're the most
competitive economy in the world we've
cut tax rates we've rolled back
regulations we've unleashed energy
we're growing rapidly I mean you're
gonna get a GDP number on Friday that's
gonna be a very impressive number some
people are in the 4 to 5 percent so all
I'm saying is we want trade to
contribute to the prosperity and by the
way not just the USA all around the
world but the system has to be fixed so
ok
no one is thrilled with subsidies I get
that including myself on the other hand
we need a backstop for our patriotic
farmers who have been hurt and if we can
open up export markets sales they will
absolutely crush it they will send out
AG exports all around the world
including China lower trade balances
employ a lot of people that's it
I'm just saying give President Trump a
chance to accomplish this very difficult
task have some patience Larry Kudlow we
all agree we want our farmers to crush
it so thank you so much for joining us
glad to see you back appreciate it very
much thank you for that take care